That's cool.
So if,
if you were going to taste some of these chocolates,
how,
how would we go about doing it or what's,
what's the next step down is experiment.
There's a lot of different ways to taste chocolate.
The most important thing is just to sort of take your time and,
and really pay attention to what is going on in your,
in your mouth.
Okay.
Um,
and every time I put a piece of chocolate in my mouth,
really try to just,
just pay attention.
Okay.
So that's,
that's really the most important thing.
And um,
and there's,
you can sort of go either way.
You can,
you can go from dark to light.
When you can go from Mike and dark.
I tend to prefer to go dark to light.
So why don't we start with the a 82% extra.
Okay.
All right.
So you'd have the cheesier same time or do you put this in a particular place in
your mouth?
I Asia for a little bit and then a and I just sort of left the,
uh,
the flavors,
put my tongue and then breed.
Um,
and just try to throw up through my mouth.
but,
you know,
just sort of just finding friends,
sort of what works for you.
Everyone has sort of a different technique that maximizes their,
their ability to be that since the flavor.
But I want to be,
see,
I can pretend to be a one stop.
Now I'm working on my repertoire for being a chocolate.
I'm missing the vocabulary.
So how would you describe this?
Well,
I like to look at eating chocolate as a,
as a very temporal thing.
And I'll,
I'll,
I'll flavor it really is,
whether it be wine or cheese or chocolate.
So in the beginning of his flavor experience,
uh,
for me,
I noticed that right on the onset there's,
there's a lot of sort of three flavors.
It's sort of a dark brown almost.
There's a little bit of a tobacco note in there,
sort of a sweet note.
And it really evolves into a sort of a slight astringency,
um,
a little bit about why note this is definitely a chocolate for it's very
complex,
some of our best means,
um,
and it,
it really has a lingering finish.
Oftentimes tasting a piece of chocolate.
I might want to even leave two or three minutes.
We won't,
we won't do that today.
They really take your take,
take your time to finish.
The finish can really change and,
and more,
even long after you've sort of have it out of your mouth,
like a good Scotch Janell,
or help the men on the camera knows this Glidden limit.
I may have to punish them for introducing a good scotch,
but it's good in moderation again.
Uh,
so let's,
let's,
if you don't mind because I've,
I've had
vast quantities of 70% because I love it.
Yeah.
Let's try something on,
on this scale.
I've never had 75.
I'd actually be curious.
It's just not,
let's try this.
This is also unique.
It's a,
it's a very different blend than any of her other.
Okay.
So now did you travel to each of these countries yourself in,
in the process of sourcing these beans?
MMM,
we asked,
yes.
Trinidad Grenada in Dominican.
Republican coastal Venezuela.
Yeah.
Over what period of time,
with the exception of Grenada,
coworker went there.
Well,
this is great.
Now,
how would you contrast that to the 82?
Well,
there are similarities and then it has a 14 us.
Um,
but the,
yeah,
until this bar I really pick up the more of a right flavor.
Um,
it's not as,
it's not as much of a drive.
This is more,
it has,
uh,
some citrus notes.
If I were going to contrast it to wine,
it seems like that would have more tenants or is this really hot?
It's uh,
and,
and part of that is the hardest part about is the sugar level.
Um,
but,
but the majority of that difference really lives in the variation between the
beans and beans can be very,
very different.
So if you have,
for example,
a coffee,
right?
So I also liked coffee.
We're talking about this before about sourcing coffee and I've been to to coffee
plants and
factories and similar in Costa Rica,
Rican,
other places.
So depending on how long you were subbing for,
it can really change the flavor.
So you have these billions that have their own characteristics from each country
and each,
I suppose latitude and so forth.
How important is the duration of roasting or all their beans roasted for roughly
the same amount of time.
Now everything has its own unique profile.
So I've been from Ghana for instance,
it's going to have a different voice time that had been from Madagascar and then
from Java to Venezuela,
Costa Rica.
So each one is very unique and needs to be really looked at.
Okay,
cool.
So do you want to,
what would be your next pic of this month?
Well,
why don't we,
I have to ask you of these.
Yeah.
You had to choose your personal favorites,
of course,
put you on the spot.
Which,
which one would it be?
And understanding that each has its own place.
Sure.
Just like a glass of wine.
Depends on if it's after dinner,
dessert,
wine or whatever.
But what would be your in general,
your indulgence of chose?
Well,
I think I probably,
I probably picked the Antilles.
I really loved the,
it's good.
That's my first time trying it.
That's really,
I mean that just,
I really love that sugar level.
Then when you say 75% okay.
So if it's 75%,
right,
it's a 25% of my volume is roughly,
uh,
if I wait,
I wait.
Yeah.
Okay.
Got It.
And do you,
you mentioned the WHO's luster unless it,
is that an emulsifier?
So what is,
so maybe like a,
you're a chocolate.
Oh,
so what,
what is less than used for,
maybe you could explain what,
what an emulsifier actually does.
An emulsifier in for,
for our purposes is really,
there's a lot of different,
there's a lot of different ingredients that go into chocolate.
Well,
especially when you're looking at,
um,
well in short,
chocolate has fat.
There's also sugar.
Um,
and so to really allow those to combine well and it requires an extensive
writing process and also the process known as conscious.
Okay.
Yeah.
And so adding soy lecithin really enables the chocolate.
How much smoother it allows it to have a better mouthfeel.
Right.
Um,
well it makes sense.
So it's like a,
if you imagine oil and water.
Yeah.
Getting those two mixed properly.
The process of emulsification conscious.
Very cool.
Do you want to try one of these?
Yeah,
let's try the,
let's try the 62 and then we'll to the number and what's a semi sweet.
Sweet is sort of a,
it's a very broadly used term as it's bitter sweet.
So what would those two,
if somebody goes into the store and they say,
okay,
well I know what dark means.
I know milk chocolate means bittersweet.
Semisweet no idea.
Yeah.
Well I think,
uh,
I'm going to get a headstart.
Yeah,
please send,
my suite is really semi sweet and bitter sweet are very wearable.
It's terms and there are some legal definitions,
but they don't really apply in a lot of ways to some of the,
some of the chocolate that we're looking at here today.
Um,
in,
in reality,
it's really one of the reasons why people are starting to use these percentages
of cocoa is because it really helps people understand exactly how dark chocolate
and,
um,
and so,
uh,
semisweet can really run the range from anywhere from 40% cocoa content all the
way to maybe 62
more.
And then a bittersweet can also range from 35 and 40% all the way to 85%.
Wow.
Um,
there's sort of an antiquated term,
so now sort of less than,
it has its own health benefits.
Also,
just as an additional excuse for me to continue to eat chocolate.